hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to allow
bizarre familiar with the hit film the
mask no not that one but trust me that's
hilarious good you'll get a lot less out
of that
no no I'm talking about the Jim Carrey
movie featuring cartoony visuals with
groundbreaking effects and spawning
several spin-offs including a TV show
and an instructional video for the
Antichrist mostly you won't be shocked
to know that the mask was based on a
comic book this is no big surprise I
mean the movie was about a weak guy
getting superpowers to save the day but
that's not the kind of comic book it was
the comic book was disturbing as hell it
was violent intense gritty and so gory
that I'm just going to warn you now that
if you're the tiniest bit squeamish you
should not watch this from here on out
no really I know it sounds silly but the
mask can be so bloody it can actually
make people queasy it is that intense oh
I see you're still watching the video so
you think you can handle it well just to
make sure you made the right choice let
me show you this little brief scene from
the comic where a guy starts cutting his
cheek yeah he's just doing that for fun
can't you just hear that spelled out
sound effect still think you can take it
well about another panel of him doing
the same thing only this time a little
closer notice how much detail they're
drawing in there with the Mane's and
such still good how about one more panel
that they include this one the closest
boozing with red where you can
practically see all the Arno whole the
purpose of this editorial is to show the
difference between two seemingly
different yet still related works of the
same name do these differences make them
stronger weaker do they help them stand
as individual pieces or confused
whatever mood and tone they were trying
to get across well let's start from the
beginning
published in 1991 the mask at first
seems to start off like the movie a
wormy dweeb named stanley ipkiss is
everybody's punching bag and wishes he
could fight back when getting a present
for his girlfriend Kathy that being the
artifact of the mask he tries it on for
fun and like the film turns into a
rain headed loon who can't be destroyed
and now operates on cartoon logic well
okay so he gets revenge like in the
movie in cartoon hilarity ensues right
not exactly
while some scenes are similar the
effects of his cartoony nature extend
only to him so when he makes a tommy gun
out of a balloon he doesn't scare the
annoyances with it he blows them into
Hamburg and when he sticks car parts in
the mechanics that ripped him off they
don't just moan at a few but jokes
they're left as bloody corpses in fact
it gets in the movie says he might
become a superhero and ends up saving
the day this if kiss goes on a killing
spree not just getting revenge on people
he doesn't like but just anyone in
general suffocating a teacher massacring
total strangers and slaughtering cops
just doing their job it's a kind of sick
it gets in the film as a hopeless
romantic who just wants to be the cool
guy if kids in the comic is a psychotic
maniac who doesn't care who he kills or
how we're in the film he's called the
title the mask in the comic he's known
as the big head killer again very
different from the movie seeing how he
never spills one drop of blood like
you're thinking to yourself I don't want
to spend an entire comic series with
this guy don't worry he dies very early
on
kathan gets fed up with his shit and
blows his brains out resulting in her
dropping off the mask to a local cop
pick a guess what the cops name is by
the way you guessed it Calloway Jim
Carrey's foil in both the movie and the
cartoon though the cartoon draws him
closer to the original source than the
movie but we're in both of those he's a
side character here he becomes the lead
no big surprise the cop tries it on and
everything starts all over again only
this time he uses the mask to try and
stop crime however he's just as violent
and blood hungry to a point where he
almost kills his best friend figuring
out he can't keep it under control he
buries the mask and the nightmare seems
to be over that is until the second run
of the series the mask returns burglars
break into Callaway's house and disarm
him trying to find a way to fight back
he digs up the mask but gets shot before
you can use it yeah kind of weird seeing
all these characters you grew up with
suddenly get horribly maimed isn't it
one of the more timid and cowardly
gangsters has the mask forced on him
once again it's used for evil he uses it
to rule the mob and take out threats to
his mafia world evil blows up an entire
wedding because of mob bosses there it's
insane how mean-spirited this comic is
feeling guilty for Calloway being shot
Cathy infiltrates big heads Network it
steals the masks for herself
what'd she find she can't destroy it she
realizes she has a responsibility to end
the mob war the masks started so she
slips it on it starts taking on the
Mafia herself only to come across
someone who seems just as it
destructible a giant of a beast named
Walter now when this character didn't
appear in the movie he does appear on
the show he was a mammoth of muscle and
strength whose entire life is violence
whenever he wants to entertain himself
he'll do something as messed up as punch
nails into his hand forming a happy face
or as shown before just cut himself for
Laughs
he's about as intimidating and as
uncomfortable a character you can get
working for the mob though he discovers
a unique fascination with the big head
killer presumably because they both seem
indestructible so while all the other
mob members try to run for their lives
Walter stays behind and won't stop until
one of them is dead this goes on for
hours until Cathy decides she can't
control it anymore and knows whoever has
it is just gonna kill everybody
eventually anyway so she decides she
doesn't give a shit and hands it over to
Walter who intriguingly has no interest
in it she's even kind of pissed off why
wouldn't he want it it doesn't seem to
make any sense
but before that can be answered Callaway
wakes up from the hospital and drives a
car into Walter losing both him and the
mask things seem to settle down until
the third revival the mask Strikes Back
now the series is especially interesting
because it was written after the success
of the movie and it clearly shows a
group of teens come across the mask and
use it not to murder but just to do teen
stuff become a rock star going to
parties Bree and even become a superhero
the violence is replaced with more wacky
visuals that fit Laura the Jim Carrey
movie that it did the comic series even
when boiling up a bomb in a police
station the cops are just covered in
black soot that kind of thing would
never have
the first series but it does allow for
some really fun and inventive artwork
and they do still sneak in some grisly
images as Walter nurses himself back to
health and is looking again for whoever
has the mask this time though he's not
screwing around when he has the mask he
knows what to do with it he slaps that
sucker on only to find it does nothing
yeah it has no effect on him this is one
of the biggest mysteries of the mask
ever in fact Walters whole relationship
with it is kind of a big question mark
why didn't he want it when it was first
offered was it more about the fight did
he want to feel he could defeat an
entity that was never defeated if so why
did he want it later
and when he did try it on how come it
didn't work what's he so destructive
naturally that the mask couldn't add
anymore
or was he so big and strong that the
mask could even fit around his face this
again would never be answered as he
launches the mask into the air and
Walter disappears forever which brings
us to the last of the series or what
many people consider the last one that
matters the hunt for Green October yeah
I think it's a dumb title too well a
bunch of assassins are searching for the
mask a father is looking after his child
who has emotionally shut herself off
from the world
this being because her mother died she
loved taug smile she barely even
communicates the father comes across
with a mask Landa though and naturally
tries at odd and uses it to go after the
bullies who mocked his kid but things
become tricky when his daughter wants to
dress up like the bighead killer for
Halloween he has to tell her no because
that's a psychotic killer even though he
is the psychotic killer but that doesn't
stop her from trying anyway as she's
booted from the school dance and made
fun of once again this is easily the
most depressing part of the series
because a lot of it does center around
this kid's pain but it does add a twist
when she comes across the mask yourself
and for the first time ever a child is
now the big head killer the climax
centers around a battle between the
assassin group Callaway once again
looking for the mask and our father and
daughter duo trying to get out of it it
certainly had more violence and gore
than the last series but the artwork was
too
to get a little too busy and maybe a bit
too rushed but there was still something
to the heavier moments that made it feel
like it was worth getting through after
that the masks mostly lived in spin-offs
trying to draw attention to more Dark
Horse Comics and looking more and more
like the Jim Carrey version less and
less like the one that started off
there's even a series called the mask
and the Joker yeah it gets pretty silly
but still whenever somebody mentions the
masks comic the first thing anyone
usually thinks is that bloody intense
version just for how shocking and
uncomfortable it was with a movie that's
a more towards kids a more friendly
humor does it really make sense to have
something so bloody and so mean-spirited
out there kind of at least if it's any
good remember how the Ninja Turtles
started off really bloody and gory
there's some x-men comics that get
pretty violent and gritty as long as
it's done well I don't really mind that
they both have their own unique style
hey I'm not gonna act like this is
Shakespeare or anything but if you look
at these comics the same way you do say
a monster movie series it's actually
rather engaging they are stories of
revenge and giving in to your inner
demons and because it switches from
person to person sometimes that can be
good and sometimes that can be bad
sometimes people have it on for just the
right amount of time others they have it
on for too long and get lost to the
madness it's a story about becoming
consumed by your bad side how much is
needed and how much goes too far you see
this kind of stuff all the time in
classic horror and yeah even classic
fantasy that mask does have a very ring
of power feel to it doesn't so you would
think the film in cartoon would be
horrible representations of the original
source material well in the same way the
60s Batman is a bad representation it's
just kind of its own thing that uses the
same characters and ideas but for
entirely different means the film of the
mask is more of a slightly adult cartoon
Tex Avery with real actors I don't think
the early 90s will been ready for
something this weird and violent yet
especially with a star like Jim Carrey
and and even the cartoon which does
borrow some elements from the comic it's
still mostly an anime version of the
but much like the 60s Batman it's a fun
segue to something different and more
adult
it's like Jekyll and Hyde mixed with the
Looney Tunes and the Punisher it's
disturbing
gory and psychotic but it's also gothic
creative and hold your interest so I say
it's fine to enjoy both versions and
what they have to offer even if they are
very different things whether it's to
hear somebody say smoking or literally
see somebody smoking there's two
different versions of the same story to
entertain whatever strange strange mood
you're in I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember so you don't have to it's
nostalgia critic D Ossining on DVD along
with some of your favorite reviews and
scenes there's new material like the
inspiration for Hyper banker a nostalgic
current review of the cinema snob movie
a nostalgic rave review of the review
must go on of nostalgia critic review of
his old home movies yes the ones mara
Wilson tormented it with bloopers a
recreation of the lost faceoff review
with nostalgia Craig's dad as Rachel the
origins of Santa Christ and mocha
shipping begins March 2 a first so order
today
and don't forget to see Doug this
weekend at c2e2 whoo 387 be there or
don't but please be there be nice
everybody dog walker here doing the
charity shout out and this week we are
doing the Kennedy Krieger Institute this
is an institution dedicated to improving
the lives of children and young adults
with pediatric developmental
disabilities and disorders of the brain
spinal cord and musculoskeletal system
as you can see they handle a great deal
for patient care special education
research and professional training they
offer treatment tailored to the
individual needs of each child and young
adult from all stages of care their
school is a leader in innovative
education with learning emotional
physical neurological and developmental
disabilities they offer a number of
school-based Hospital based and
recreational programs designed to unlock
the potential inside each and every
student every person deserves a chance
to be everything they can be and this is
an institution that tries to make that
possible
you can go to their website or you can
hear stories on their youtube channel to
get more information check them both out
and see what you can do to help people
function to the most of their potential